je quittais on vous l'a promis et viale
et la langue ou l'autre avec trois
listes
les muscles
alors à bagdad a exhorté lors d'autres
pays je vous remercie d'être là tout va
laisser leur boulot fini les fans au jeu
de quoi pardon je vous reconnais c'est
leur boulot pour mon pardon non alors
c'est la star du football féminin et la
haine je vous le dis alors comment ça va
depuis ce reportage sur téléfoot vous
êtes une star on ne parle que de vous
c'est vrai ça va mais je vous dis je
sais que vous êtes une grande fan de
l'émission vous regardez très souvent je
jean luc lemoine
l'eau est ce que vous pouvez faire ça
pour nous parce que je crois que il n'ya
que vous qui pouvez faire ça jean luc
lemoine ne dort jamais mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui que moi non mais jamais
une ambulance mais jamais c'est
impossible de faire donc c'est est-ce
que l'or ou là mais pas du tout à
l'heure celui qui donc ne pourra pas la
toucher je viens danser avec ses 6 mai
se faire mais il peut danser avec elle
ça va c'est pas une émission érotique
non plus ça va on se calme l'or est ce
que vous pouvez faire quelques petites
danses avec jean luc lemoine je crois
qu'il n'y a que vous qui pouvez faire ça
allait aller julie
toujours à paris j'adore les alertes
répétées avec les atours et jean luc
lemoine qui n'ose pas vous dire ça n'est
jamais arrivé
j'en passe
m
tarot pour le premier épisode de 37 et
des crêpes au nutella guillaume balas
lambada lambada attention lambada c'est
parti le temps qu'ils la trouvent à mon
avis sera 22 heures mais bon on va le
tenter quand même été un tout petit bout
c'est quoi cette merde
why should attention je peux voir
jean-luc danser la lambada
la latence
voilà
moi
j'sais pas si vous avez vu la tête de
lens où les compter a vu jean michel
arrivé à l'agresseur merci à tous
d'avoir est avec nous son amérique
latine
merci à tous ceux qui est pas la télé
cette odeur
tu dois t on joue tous les fans 12 qui
mettent des messages sur twitter
c'est l'inversé